this morning the FBI indicted more than
40 people including well-known actors
and CEOs for committing fraud to get
their kids into elite universities yeah
yeah no one involved things like bribing
teachers to take their kids SAT exams
and receiving athletic scholarships even
if their kids didn't play sports
if their kids didn't play sports at all
and weren't the least bit athletic
mm-hmm these people were rigging things
so it looked like their kids were
athletes yeah I was blown away by this
and I've been thinking about it all day
and we've all been talking about it and
I wanted to find out more so here's what
I did I invited a USC student here to
chat about it please welcome USC
basketball starting center David
Holloway let's get him out here
[Applause]
hi David so it's says here you play
Center for USC or the Center for the
basketball team yes sir
okay says here you're seven feet two
inches and you weigh 310 pounds seven
foot three I grew a little freshman year
okay
there is I'm sorry there's no way you
weigh 310 pounds well not on this planet
but on Jupiter easily that much okay
listen I'm sorry but you were clearly
way too small to play Division one
college basketball so I'm gonna guess
mr. Holloway you come from a wealthy
family father says never to discuss
money all he cares about is watching me
play basketball in Holloway arena
Holloway arena yeah it's the brand new
arena father built it's on Holloway
Avenue okay I think we get where you're
coming from let's speak to another
athlete all right here to speak on this
matter is also a USC freshman I'm told
she's an african-american gymnastics
star please welcome
Alana Richardson let's bring her out
here
actually that's meals ok forgot sit
Alanna Richardson everybody